can you talk about your writing process
how you plan out a screenplay
how it evolves yeah um i guess
you know it always starts with an idea
uh which is
how we get to ideas you know who really
knows i mean they just kind of
inspiration strikes
for me it's it's like i get really um
into
things like worlds you know maybe i'm
like oh like i'm really into
surfing right now you know and i want to
do a surfing idea or or
i get really obsessed with with a thing
uh
and then maybe an idea will emerge from
that or maybe i'll
write a surfing movie or whatever the
case may be um
but once you have the idea and i've
probably written it down in a google doc
somewhere
i'll start to start to just what i call
like word vomit
you know just free form write
paragraphs of what this idea could be
i try to write the what effectively
would be the wikipedia
entry for the plot summary of of a
script
that's what i try to aim to get so um
i'll just really you know we open up
with this and then we see
you know karen and she's sitting over
there and she's doing an interview and
then blah blah and i'll just
just stream of conscious it um
and then once i kind of build that out
to where i can
tell a whole story that's when i'll
start to refine
uh more of an outline and then once we
kind of get the outline going
that's usually when i'll just say all
right i have enough of an outline i kind
of understand
where i want to go with this now i just
have to start page one and actually
start typing
sure and then what if we want to add
what if you read through it and you
realize
okay this is to vanilla we've gotta
we've gotta put in some conflict
i think yeah i think um
karen throws her questions down right
right
i feel like uh that's kind of the the
discovery that happens along the way i
mean if you're talking about
you know macro level your script has a
problem because
it doesn't have x component um i mean
ideally you're
you have solved for that early on or or
you've
you've figured that out um you know in
your outline process at least that's
what i do for me
um also too with a lot of things that
i'm i'm writing
you know i always have references of
other films that
maybe have done it well like you know if
i'm i'm from writing a drama maybe
there's other dramas that
i'm looking to for inspiration so if
there's a similar thing in my script i
think i try to figure out okay well
what did they do like what was their
catalyst or what was their you know
uh you know b story or how what did they
do in their
second act um you know what what am i
doing in mine you know
how does that work or how do they solve
for you know some kind of conflict or
how do they create conflict
uh and then so ideally it solved in the
uh outline process for me but then as
you're writing it
you know you just kind of let it steer
where it goes you know you have
a little bit of that discovery process
uh along the way
have you ever written a screenplay
without an outline i
i actually haven't done that um which is
interesting i mean i think that that
would
i think for some people that could work
really well um
but i don't think for me i mean i don't
know i've never done it
i i don't i don't know if that would
work for me i do have a friend
who is also a writer who recently just
did that for himself for the very first
time where he
he's written many scripts and he always
outlines in full detail and he actually
did that because he was like i just want
to try it um
and he ended up getting through it and
he was like oh yeah
it's actually it was pretty cool it was
pretty uh you know uh it was an
interesting you know experiment
and um i don't know it was just more
creative in the sense that he felt like
very uh
you know unchained to like some kind of
structure that he had to
you know create for himself uh but with
that being said he was like yeah but i
probably wouldn't do it again
so yeah i don't know i don't know but
for me yeah
it's probably something that i wouldn't
necessarily try
okay interesting so so would was this
friend
very regimented did they they're they're
sort of a planner
yeah i think they definitely he
definitely had a process that he always
did
you know which was handwritten this and
then outlined this
and and you know uh doing
timelines and etc so so for him it was
definitely a
a break from from his typical form
interesting do you think you'll
you'll try that uh i mean
maybe maybe one day yeah i won't rule it
out but for right now
uh probably not no okay too too risky
yeah
i mean i think that's amazing if if
people can just
do it um without an outline but you know
i i
i also think that there's probably a
point where you can over outline things
as well
uh because because at a certain point
it's like you just gotta go in and
and start writing uh and and no script
that i've ever finished
has been like tit for tat exactly like
the outline
i mean there there's been many times
that i've kind of deviated along the way
but the outline just kind of helps give
me uh
you know structure and rails to to go on
you know someone left an interesting
comment on the topic of over planning
and that may have been a joke but they
just put can you talk about psych evals
for your
uh your characters yeah so i mean that
might be going down too much of a rabbit
hole
yeah and spending too much time but i
just thought it was interesting
yeah i mean everyone has their process
and maybe that's helpful for
certain writers to you know know what
the their character's fifth grade
birthday was like but like
for me it i i don't find that type of
outlining and
and prepping uh necessary
are you outlining the plot yourself or
your character's transformation
um i think i'm doing a little bit of
both i guess
um certainly what i need to actually
start writing
is for me just like the plot but
while i'm working on the plot i mean i'm
really thinking about okay well what is
the theme of this movie like what's the
arc
of these characters that is gonna happen
um so
that's something that you know if i if i
have like a google doc that i have
all my notes in and i have the wikipedia
plot summary
of uh you know the the movie that i'm
writing i might have a different page
that's dedicated to just like
the theme and uh the arc of the
character uh and if i don't actually end
up
writing it out specifically like what
the you know
character's transformation is going to
be um all i will do at some point the
exercise
if i'm like you know uh talking to a
friend i'll explain to them what the arc
of the character is just to see if i can
actually
explain what it is if that makes sense
because i feel like
you know uh if i'm talking about a story
i i should be able to explain
you know what this character's journey
is so i should be able to verbalize it
so i'll actually practice
oh yeah this character started like this
and then throughout the journey they
actually discover this and
and that's what it's all about and this
is the theme of the film and everything
so
um yeah i will
how do your outlines look i guess they
look kind of two ways
one is it just looks like long pages of
of words that are just like a blob uh
and then there's an
actual outline that you know i might
follow kind of like a
three-act structure outline that you
know there's there's templates like uh
what's the book called save the cat uh
for instance like
that structure right there where you
have like you know
uh all right here's the opening image
and then get to page five and here's the
theme and then page 12 is the catalyst
and then page
30 is the b story and and whatever that
structure is
um i will do the work to kind of at
least write that out
um just for myself to reference
and um yeah those are usually like the
two kind of outlines that i'll have
when do you go back in and really refine
the dialogue
um for me i spend a lot of time
well i i have a hard time moving on
to the next scene if i can't at least
if it's not at least like coherent right
or if the dialogue is not at least
something that i somewhat enjoy like i
can definitely
uh move on if it's if it's not perfect
that's okay
but um i i do as i'm writing spent time
trying to make the dialogue at least
sound somewhat good and then later on in
the
in the you know the rewrite when you get
to like the second draft or the third
draft
you're constantly redoing the dialogue
then as well
um and then two if you ever get the
chance to like have friends read it or
maybe you know
you'll go so far as to do like a table
read with friends uh that's another good
way to do it because you'll hear people
say it out loud and you might rewrite a
line then uh if it sounds clunky to you
do you ever when you hear it read out
loud do you do you realize you know what
i've overwritten this
in real life we would never explain it
this way or
yeah i think i think so i mean i think
that there's more succinct ways to
to say things all the time um and i
think for
you know especially if you're writing i
don't know
a comedy or something like you always
want to be you know very succinct with
your jokes
et cetera so uh hearing things out loud
can be a great way to
figure out how to write a line better
especially if it's not
you doing it because you know i'll spend
a lot of time on my computer reading
stuff out loud
but you know hearing a friend read it or
hearing maybe an actor read it
i think is is even more helpful you
talked about leaving easter eggs
sometimes in your music videos
yeah how do you do that in your scripts
and and why
what why is one easter egg important to
you rather than doing none
um i think it's just it's just fun i
mean i think it's just kind of you know
whenever you're writing you're always
putting a little bit
of yourself on the page in some kind of
way and so with little like easter eggs
or references that you think
are funny or cool or kitschy um it's
just a way to kind of keep it
interesting for yourself and
and to you know infuse the script with
your own sort of personal
touch i guess if you were to explain an
easter egg to a new writer
can you tell us like a popular movie
where there's like a very clever easter
egg that's been left
oh well i mean you could watch you know
uh
any of the marvel movies if you're a fan
of like you know the marvel superhero
movies i mean those things are riddled
with easter eggs like if you're
if you're a comic book fan or you read
the comic books and you know these
characters very well
uh they're constantly putting in
references to other storylines or
writers or artists who were the original
creators of those superheroes or their
referencing like other superheroes
within the universe so
uh those movies do a great job you know
incorporating easter eggs and and you
can tell that the
the filmmakers and the the creative
people behind those movies
probably have a lot of fun thinking of
what we can put in here
that people will get excited about
you